speaking of law and order
radical
trumpist
republican congressman madison cawthorne
has been charged for driving with no
license
here's the key word
a second time
um north carolina congressman madison
cawthorne charged with driving with
revoked license for second time
he now has a court date
congressman madison cawthorne has been
charged with driving with a revoked
license a misdemeanor that carries up to
20 days in jail the 26 year old
republican was pulled over march 3rd in
cleveland county about an hour and a
half southeast of asheville by the
highway patrol
along with the misdemeanor cawthorne is
facing two pending citations for
speeding in different counties highway
patrol spokesperson sergeant marcus
bethea said march 9 he could confirm
that the three citation numbers are
pending matters the cleveland county
stop happened around shelby
um trooper tyler gantt
saw a 2019 toyota truck cross the center
line not you know pretty reckless
driving the driver was identified as
david madison cawthorne i guess is i
guess madison's his middle name uh
during the course of the investigation
it was determined the driver's license
was in a state of revocation he doesn't
have an actual valid license he was
charged with driving while license
revoked they claim to be about law and
order and they're not
they claim that it's the left that's
doing all the election stuff but it's
actually them and in particular and this
is not a joke when it comes to motor
vehicle stuff you would think that
madison cawthorne would understand the
consequences of irresponsible driving
unlicensed driving all this stuff
he's in a wheelchair because of a car
accident he was involved in when he was
younger
in which if i recall correctly his
friend the driver
fell asleep and i'm not even going to
speculate on what that means
fell asleep can mean a lot of different
things when it comes to traffic
accidents um and he is regularly
speeding crossing the center line
driving with no no valid license guys
come on it's it's the the double
standards and the hypocrisy i know they
don't care about them but at a certain
point it's almost like a skit they're
such uh hypocrites um no word as to
whether he pulled the do you know who i
am sort of game but this is a guy who
regularly you know to say he's
deliberately breaking the law we would
need to know his state of mind but he's
at least at minimum accidentally
breaking it remember when he tried to
bring a gun on a plane he had a gun in
his carry-on and he tried to bring it on
a plane oh he forgot where it was oh no
it's just he's a congressman sir
responsible congressman well if you
forget where your gun is
that doesn't sound like responsible gun
ownership one of the principles of
responsible gun ownership is you should
always know whether the gun is loaded
and you should always know where the gun
is
the gun was in his carry-on he didn't
believe or
he was not aware that it was in his
carry-on that's negligence but always oh
no these are just it's these are just
accidents
who's gonna who's he gonna blame for
this one antifa
uh black lives matter
critical race theory
joe biden socialism or maybe transgender
kids or george soros i don't know the
party of personal responsibility
very quick to say these were accidents
and certainly someone else is actually
to blame here so
second time second time caught driving
without a valid license
madison cawthorne
we have a situation right now where many
companies want and need to hire people
quickly
but it is difficult to find the right
candidates and workable is going to help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process workable helps you cast
the widest net possible by posting your
jobs to over 200 of the top job boards
with just one click it helps you
evaluate and hire quickly with modern
tools like video interviews and
e-signatures you can automate some of
those repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews whether you're hiring for
your coffee shop or your engineering
team workable is exactly what you need
to hire the right people fast
start hiring today with a risk-free
15-day trial if you hire during the
trial which many do
it will cost you nothing
just go to workable.com
podcast to start hiring the link is down
below